nfl figure you'd want to watch a game
with in honor of reports that sean mcvay
was courted by monday night football for
this year
ask me the question chris to determine
pick number one all right rodney
harrison who you sit next to
every sunday is one of only two members
in the history of the nfl of the 30-30
club
30 sacks 30 interception who
is the other member of the 30-30 club
jameis winston doesn't count no it
doesn't
nope thank you 30 career sacks 30 career
interceptions i would say it's your
former teammate rondae barber oh
good guess but it is not uh hit wow
i know i know uh it is a ray lewis
one ray lewis wow yeah
wow i know i know how in the hell did he
have 30 interceptions
yup rondae was in the 2020 club i know
that
something uh so it's pretty special i
think he ended up with 28 sacks so he
just missed out all right so first pick
here we go
go ahead take the pick i know you're
gonna take go ahead who do you think i'm
gonna take no just tell me who you think
i'm gonna go ahead
no go ahead you take it you take it i'm
taking it i'm taking andy reid wow
expect that huh wow no yeah i mean come
on
andy reed watching a football game with
first off you know we're gonna have a
spread like
the food is gonna be a plentiful right
but he's gonna eat it all well okay i
think i'm bigger
i'm gonna push his big butt out of the
way and get some too he's not gonna just
boss me around in the food line
but then you know andy is just got such
a great comfortable way about him i feel
like he'd be one of those guys i could
sit in the recliner next to and we'd
just hit it off like we've been friends
forever even though we've only talked a
handful of times in our life
and then he's a great storyteller you
know between the stories with brett
favre and patrick mahomes and things
like that i just feel like i'd have a
a grand old time i'd be right at home so
i'm picking big red
i'm stunned i know you are stunned i am
shocked and i am appalled
you have changed chris you have to go
back and reevaluate your priorities as
you approach your own 40th birthday
which is coming up
very very soon how do you not take
your guy and my guy aaron rodgers
he's got scotch he's got tequila now i
drink scotch
i drink sipping tequila as well see
here's the thing and aaron rodgers would
never admit this but i'll go ahead and
say it
other than the obvious you know physical
differences like he's got real skill and
i don't
i think he and i are a lot alike i think
we have the same sense of humor
i think we look at things the same way
and i think one of the reasons it drives
him
crazy is i know how to get right into
that little nugget inside of his chest
and poke at it right
yes because i i just i know what makes
him tick i know how he thinks i know how
he operates because i'm the same way
i think we'd have a hell of a time after
he beat me up but
and i'm telling you i'm telling you and
and also
he would say in a private setting
what he really thinks what he believes
you'd find out what he thinks about the
different players and what he thinks
about who has the skills and who doesn't
and where someone makes a good decision
a bad decision
and he wouldn't sugarcoat it and i don't
sugarcoat it
so i think we'd have a hell of a time i
i mean i i actually agree with you
i think you would you're both like very
cerebral quirky
yes hold a lot of things in because you
want to get people
back and do all that so you're right you
guys have so many snarky comments
together after a few drinks
who knows what the hell it how he might
be hap he bet by the end of that
that game he'd be sitting there helping
you snarky comment snarky comment paste
copy and you guys would be like really
best buddies it'd be unbelievable
um okay i'm staying on the coach thing
here a little longer just because
those are the ones i find most
intriguing i think the next one i'm
going to
is sean payton i'm going with sean
payton i mean first off i
i love sean payton his attitude you know
he wears his heart on his sleeve
whatever kind of isn't in his brain he
kind of spits it out whether he thinks
it's
gonna you know cause some turmoil or not
if he believes it he'll say it
you know and i think he's the kind of
guy too we sit there we can really get
into some x's and o's i would love to
pick his brain
like okay they're breaking the huddle
you know what are you looking at here
what are you expecting all those things
to me he's one of the great offensive
geniuses
in the history of the sport has an edge
about him like a bill parcells too where
i feel like you know
me and four letter words and everything
i could just let it fly all day long
and we'd have fun and uh yeah you know
we'd have you know some good new orleans
desserts and
i think sean would kick throw back a few
drinks too and i like that too so i i'm
definitely putting sean payton towards
the top of my list
well we saw that during the draft he had
all sorts of uh
snacks and candy items on the table you
know none of which were nfl approved
which was a little a little subtle a
little subtle message
i could get the money that was
circulated yeah oh absolutely you know
um
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go bill belichick
with mine and i'm surprised he's lasted
this long on the board because if you
want to know what's really happening in
front of you
and they say all the time you get him
away from
football as it relates to his own
strategic interests and he's a different
guy all together
i i think that you know he would break
down in
expert detail everything that's
happening a full and complete
understanding
of why a team is doing a certain thing
why they should have done it what they
should have done differently
what they should do here what they
shouldn't do here
and and once he got going it it would be
far more interesting than anything
you're ever going to hear anywhere else
i i mean like yes i agree
all right the reason i didn't pick him
is because i think there's a good chance
you could be sitting there for three
hours and nothing said either
that's why i picked him he might not say
crap to you he might just sit there and
keep looking at you and going on to
cincinnati on to cincinnati
so that's why i didn't pick them even
though i know
it would be very intriguing to
you know pick a guy like that's brain
and you know
one thing one thing that happens yeah
one thing that happens at press
conferences if you like every once in a
while he gets asked a question about
some
arcane football thing and he just goes
for 10 minutes i think if it's
disconnected to his strategic interest
he will talk and talk and talk about
football i would agree with you with
that i
i felt like that way in my interview
process with bill that he was very
loved to talk about that type of stuff
and uh he's a historian of the game as
we know and if you've seen those shows
with the nfl 100
all right i got to go to one player here
i've been thinking about like
who are the crazy players in football
that i'd want to watch a game with you
know i thought of the derwin james and
the
jamal adams and melvin ingrams and jalen
ramsey's of the world
but i i i got it george kittle all right
george kittles who i want to watch the
game with
i mean first off it's constant
entertainment there's not going to be
any like commercial break i mean it's
going to be commercial
let me talk to this crazy freaking dude
over here who knows what he'll do
and you know i just think we can have a
lot of fun talk ball
be silly be guys i mean he's just to me
one of the more electrifying
personalities in football right now with
a handful of other guys
i think kittle kind of stands out to me
he's kind of the new age grunk right
and i just think that would be fun just
to be there and be around him
you know if we were going all time
unlimited john madden would have been my
first pick second pick and third pick
and i just want to mention him because
really
he's on my list the way we all process
and understand football but i got to go
with kind of a hybrid between aaron
rodgers and bill belichick
and it's your guy john gruden right
because he's got the depth and the
knowledge
but at the same time he's going to
criticize everything he sees
even when it goes well he's going to
find a way to criticize
and say they could have done it better
than the way they did it
and he'll have that snarl on his face
the whole time
and during the commercial breaks we'll
go back and break down the things that
had happened
during the drive that just ended so give
me give me your guy john gruden
uh for uh you know that uh three hours
or longer of sitting there watching the
game and then breaking it all down after
i hear that he's be fun he'd have a lot
of jokes he could kick back some beers
he'd be funny as hell he really would
he's one of the greatest storytellers
i've ever been around you know and
that's where i mean we're doing this in
in light of sean mcvay who was also on
my list
mcveigh would be one of those guys i'd
put on there too i mean that we should
mention because
his play recall and all that stuff i
mean he's kid
kid genius as we've talked about so uh
yeah there's some good names to pick
from here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports